C'est extraordinaire.
C'est l'état d'esprit, je dois le dire,
c'est l'état d'esprit dont vous avez besoin pour collaborer efficacement.
En restant dans notre silo, nous pouvons réussir.
Mais quand nous prenons du recul et que nous tendons la main,
des miracles peuvent se produire.
Les mineurs peuvent être secourus,
les patients peuvent être sauvés,
de jolis films peuvent être créés.
Je pense qu'il n'y a pas de meilleur conseil que celui-ci :
regardez sur votre gauche, sur votre droite.
A quelle vitesse pouvez-vous trouver les talents uniques, compétences
et espoirs de votre voisin,
et à quelle vitesse pouvez-vous chacun communiquer ce que vous apportez ?
Car, pour collaborer afin d'ériger le futur que nous pouvons créer,
et que nul ne peut créer seul,
c'est l'état d'esprit dont nous avons besoin.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)